says the mazda 3 is serious competition
for the volkswagen golf and unlike it
the mazda also comes in sedan and
fastback
versions hatchback or fastback that is
the question
since the mazda3 was introduced in 2003
it has been praised for its excellent
driving dynamics
now in its third generation it not only
handles well but is also very
comfortable
mazda calls its design philosophy kodo
soul emotion
it's about muscular vigor
dynamic poise plus elegant detail
its distinctive front body lines and
powerful stance embody this philosophy
the model we are testing is the 2.2
liter diesel producing 110 kilowatts of
power with sports nav trim
it accelerates from zero to 100
kilometers an hour in 8.1 seconds the
price in germany is just over 25 and a
half thousand euros
the signature mazda face featuring the
winged grille flows seamlessly around
the sleek by xenon headlights enhancing
the car's sporty dynamic presence the
sculpted forms create an impression of
powerful forward movement the stance is
strong and wide character lines flow
along the body inspired the company says
by the powerful smooth movement of
nature
the problem with sedans in general is
the limited height of the trunk but here
in the mazda 3 the opening is nice and
wide and she prefers the look of a sedan
so they felt mirror
the interior is clean and uncluttered
all the instruments are in easy reach
there is a pleasing counterpoint between
the cockpit's chrome detailing and its
dark tones
the mazda 3's interior resembles that of
mazda's other models it's neat serious
and spacious without being cavernous
michelle doesn't feel squeezed in behind
the wheel or lost in space
the mazda 3 hugs the road the handling
is impeccable mazda's sky active
technology focused on lowering weight to
enhance performance and efficiency gets
the best out of the engines increasing
torque while lowering co2 emissions and
fuel consumption
michelle says the 110 kilowatt diesel
engine makes this a fun car to drive
it's responsive and the ride is nice and
sporty
the sky active body is both lightweight
and ultra strong and the sky active
chassis provides an ideal blend of
precise handling and ride comfort
the result is a dynamic nimble drive it
is really fun even on a routine run to
work or to the supermarket